oh i was just saying that i think it's
important to be an asset to a guy's life
yeah i i definitely agree with women
being in a relationship and you don't
have i'm definitely not for splitting
bill bills and all that but you need to
contribute you need to be of value but
not just in a relationship in life like
if you
if you're with a partner you should do
stuff together like okay maybe he's
cooking you said you were cooking and
cleaning was he doing anything or he was
just um
there
no he was he was doing other things okay
well yeah can i can i do a follow-up
with you yeah and you tell me yo hey
that's too personal hey i don't know i
want to go there but
you know ally married the guy that she
was dating
coco plans on marrying i guess the guy
that you're dating that's something you
envisioned but you were being an asset
to your relationship
cooking cleaning being an asset but you
didn't end up marrying him so is that
like
you know i kind of was being the asset
but it didn't work out so i kind of
regret it um no i don't i don't regret
that no um
i mean
i think i could have had that if i want
i just didn't see it long term um so did
you break up with him or he broke up
with you
oh you ended up yeah i just didn't see
it long term um and i was i just i think
a lot of girls waste their 20s with guys
that are like boyfriends and not
husbands and i just didn't want to do
that
um so yeah i ended that but i don't
regret doing that because i think one it
gave me like relationship skills so i
understand a little bit better like how
i can help a guy in the future let's
talk about this girls wasting their 20s
okay and how old are you by the way i'm
25. you're 25 yes you are 27 20 coco 31
31 okay so you guys are in mid-20s early
30s
um i've been very vocal about this i'll
as a guy waste your 20s as much as you'd
like your 20s are your time to [ __ ] up
make mistakes do stupid stuff date the
wrong girl
as a guy
it's you're able to do that as a girl
you can do that in your early 20s you do
not want to do that in your late 20s
okay
um let's talk about that why is it
important for a girl to actually
not waste their 20s well your value
decreases as a woman the older you get
and your opportunity to give a man
children um it's less and less the older
you get yeah you can have
ivf but most guys don't want to spend
like what is it 30k
16k 16k yeah i work most of the time
yeah so i mean if a guy can pick you
know a 35 year old woman or a 25 year
old woman he's going to pick the 25 year
old woman you think so yeah why because
of the ability to be fertile yeah
partially and like men
they surveyed men between the ages of
like 20 and 80 and all of them
preferred girls around the age of 22 23.
yeah this is what rola was saying sexual
sexual marketplace so um i mean i think
there's other sexual market value i
don't want to mess that up yeah i mean i
think there's other things that come
into play but i think men when it comes
to building a family and you also have
the issue of you know the more
relationships that a girl has been and
the more traumatized she's going to be
the more she the more access she has to
complain about yeah and that just
happens the older you get well let me
let me actually give you a different
side of the coin because i remember you
were very um
open about this you said you are so much
better of a woman as a female as a
girlfriend at 30 31 as you were at 24.
yeah explain why
i feel in your 20s you're just you're
starting to learn who you are and you
see what you like when you dislike and
i think that in your 20s
you shouldn't be dating somebody
like if you're 21 22 you should not be
in a relationship for like five years
i think you should if it happens great
good for you but i think that you should
explore who you are as a person and by
that you can also date multiple guys so
you can see what you like what you're
dislike so you think that a woman who's
21 22 she gets out of college she should
go through her whole phase you never
said that i said it you did
no i never said you should go through a
whole face you said date multiple guys
so i did not say it has to be oh but we
know what i mean i think you should
live your life
and see who you are so then later on
when you're ready and when you're
emotionally mature because when you're
21 2 you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on at least i didn't i mean i
moved here when i was 22. so
in this past eight nine years i changed
a lot because i learned who i am
what if i got married to a guy that i
was dating when i was 21 22 because my
goal in life was to get married i would
i didn't know who i am okay so how can
you get married and be with somebody
but you're not even
sure who you are yeah so how do you guys
grapple with that because you're
basically saying the exact opposite
thing that she's saying so would you
guys engage and have this conversation
what that means you don't know who you
are you're trying to figure out what you
want in life like i just i've always
known who i am well not everybody is the
same
i just don't get what girls mean when
they say that
what what is it like they want to just i
mean i get it they kind of want to
figure it out so
i think there's some truth to some of
the things that coco says because it's
one of the reasons that pearl probably
knew who she was when she knew it is
because you had really great parents you
know in a well-rounded two-parent
household but i i actually don't agree
entirely with you know the red pill
about oh go ahead and get out there and
get a husband as young as you can
i think you have the most leverage in
your youth i can agree to that i think
you have a lot more options at 20 to 24
but i can say that i don't think most
american women know themselves until
they're 24 and then i mean even after
that like there's a lot of narcissistic
clueless women running around out here
and they're gonna be a liability the
problem is is that they let the
narcissism run its way into their 30s
and they're surprised like why didn't my
life work out it's because you need a
reality check and that's i think that's
why pearl and i have the content that we
do to just give women a heads up like
hey like your 20s you could really be on
a mission so you want to talk about oh i
want a career and i want a husband okay
fabulous amazing set it up by 24. if
you're hard charging and you're an
intelligent woman you can set it up for
at 24 and then you can pursue dating
full force can you define just set it up
by 24. have a foundation of platform you
can have a bachelor's degree if you want
you can have internships so you can have
connections networking whatever you need
as a foundation so that way
you've done most of the hard work and
you can still take on that relationship
and continue to do harder work in your
career if you need
a question for you guys
it's an easy answer but also a
complicated answer are men and women
equal no no
no
men and women did you aunt did you say
no as well
i didn't vocalize but yeah they're not
equal
explain why men and women are not equal
go ahead ally you want to go first we're
just not the same we're not the same and
if we're not the same then how could we
be equal so we can talk about you know
women being equal but i'm not even sure
that's a worthwhile conversation because
there's always going to be somebody that
has advantages in different areas
compared to yourselves men are stronger
and they're bigger and they can run
faster because i don't know if you know
this but strength is it's sprinting is
more about strength like i can't sprint
at all and then there's things i'll beat
your ass in a race right now girl
right you know and uh so i can attest to
that because a lot of women think that
they're as strong as a man and that's
that's just not physically possible they
have so much more to solve what about in
the in the workforce are men and women
equal no no there should not be
professional women cry in the bathroom
is a lot i don't think men do that my
boss did your boss pearl you because you
and ally both said no immediately and
then coco took a second she thought
about it but why why do you say when men
and women are not equal i didn't think
about it i just didn't say it okay well
i just men and women are different we're
not the same we're biologically
different like we're just not yeah well
our women are chemically different every
single day so even like i i run a pretty
successful youtube channel i have a show
similar like similar to this setup in my
living room and i like bring people in
and a lot of my business decisions are
run through men and i think a lot of
times you're going to find like
successful women there's like a man
behind them helping them with the
decisions because like men are just more
logical than women because again we get
our emotions into it because we're
chemically different every single day
but the counterargument that i hear okay
is well you know men have been running
the world for years
and aren't all the wars started by men
that's not true
this is the counter argument that you
hear men start all the wars world war
one world war ii french revolution
america it's all men start in the
written genghis khan the mongols they
they do it all but they also built the
world boom
so they they allowed
they allowed us to enter the workforce
they had to tame the world so we could
enter it
like if we were still in like the old
days we would need someone to protect us
so you guys are not male haters
whatsoever your male appreciation no i
mean shout out to the men out there i
have i've built in the world i mean i
have five brothers so when girls say
things like men or trash men are the
problem
i'm like okay you can speak for yourself
like the men you pick are the problems
because i i have five really great
brothers i have a really great father
and so if you have an issue with men
like that's a you problem and don't put
that on me by the way that is very
powerful go
i want to add just because he's a good
brother doesn't mean he's a good
boyfriend
well yeah but that's on the girl to pick
you pick who you date like if you're
halfway a decent looking girl you have a
million options who you can date so i'm
not gonna when these girls come crying
to me because they hate all the boys
they they chose to date like that's your
own fault i mean i agree with that
whenever like i have this thing called
wobble cocodo every tuesday and friday
and i put a little question box and
people ask me questions and they are
sending me you know screenshots and
their issues and they're explaining what
this guy did but i'm like you're letting
this happen so let's say you have a guy
who only invites you over for netflix
and chill and you still show up and then
you're expecting him to like put you on
a pedestal and fly you to paris or
something but like you're letting it
happen and those are the same girls
that'll cry on tick tock and be like oh
boo hoo poor me and i'm like i don't
feel bad for you
i don't you picked him this must be
controversial with the women like you're
friends with you grew up with this is
not like are there like you're a woman
hater you're like but i'm a woman okay
i've picked bad guys before too i'm not
perfect but in every situation i've been
in i was like you know what that was my
own damn fault
usually is our fault yeah by the way
that is really hard to do whether in a
relationship or in the workforce look
yourself in the mirror and be like i
gotta own this l right here it's because
of my dad every time i try to be
emotional my dad is like your fault
your fault and he's right like i just
think your lot in life it's it's your
own fault and if you end up alone
because you can't pick men like that's
on you
i agree